congratulations kevin durant it has been
announced today that you have been named
to the 75th anniversary team for the nba
what does that mean to you
it's just
man it means a lot i mean it means
everything to be honest i mean you want
to
leave your mark in this league on the
game on a game of basketball itself and
to be amongst the greatest
that this game has ever seen you know
just to be in that same company is
pretty sweet so
as a kid i seen a 50th anniversary
you know and i always dreamt of having
one of those jackets on and be amongst
that group and
being in that brotherhood so it feels
good to be a part of it now
well you're certainly in it
congratulations again
you talk about making your mark you
already have one championship right so
here you are in brooklyn it's game one
of the season what makes you think that
this team has what it takes what makes
you guys special
uh we have a we got a lot of talent on
this team we got a great coaching staff
and good support system that can uh and
that's a good start to have right there
is
but for us we got a
veteran group of guys that been through
a lot and hopefully we build on that and
make it a good season so you know we uh
we don't want to be you know
we don't want to round out the shape in
the first game i know that's how tough
that is but you know we want to start
this thing off right
so that would be going for your third
championship if you do make that happen
this season
you know what a tough road that is and
you just talked about the long-term
goals
things happened differently for you all
this season than you expected with kyrie
not being in the picture what does that
change for you especially on the
offensive end
yeah man guys don't have to step up and
feel that
that void i mean he uh he meant a lot to
our team so but i think we got guys that
are ready for this opportunity there's
always next man up mentality and pro
sports so
we trust everybody in this locker room
to be professionals and do their jobs
and you know we're looking forward to
starting the season off all right thanks
so much for stopping good luck tonight
thank you